un phénomène devenu mondial initié à
ottawa il ya quinze jours par des
camionneurs venus de tout le territoire
canadien le convoi de la liberté où
convoi anti restrictions sanitaires
s'étend aujourd'hui au delà des
frontières canadiennes et trouvent un
écho à travers le monde en
nouvelle-zélande plus d'un millier de
manifestants des centaines de camions et
autres camping cars sont rassemblés
depuis mardi devant le parlement de
wellington je crois en la liberté
je ne crois pas que ce pass sanitaire
soit juste une chose beaucoup de choses
sont même injuste je veux juste être
capable de manifester europe et beaucoup
de gens ici font la même chose nous
étions très content de la réaction de ja
sinndar dern face au co vide 19 pendant
le premier confinement mais maintenant
elle est devenue folle on veut qu'elle
nous laisse tranquille qu'elle nous
laisse faire ce qu'on veut nous sommes
des adultes
depuis le début du rassemblement de
violents heurts ont éclaté entre les
opposants opel sanitaires et la police
néo zélandaise qui a procédé à plus de
120 arrestations
vienne paris bruxelles et le mouvement
pour la liberté s'enracine également
dans les capitales européennes en
autriche des centaines de manifestants
ont convergé vendredi vers le centre de
vienne malgré l'interdiction des
autorités
depuis le 5 février dernier l'autriche
est devenue le premier pays européen à
imposer la vaccination plus de 18 ans
situation similaire aux pays bas où des
dizaines de camions bloquent le centre
ville de lae avec un mot d'ordre lutter
contre les restrictions sanitaires
imposées pendant la crise nous verrons
combien de temps ils resteront pour
l'instant nous restons ici et nous
verrons comment ça se passe
on dit qu'un groupe se rend à bruxelles
depuis les pays bas ont dit qu'un autre
groupe se rendrait à paris le groupe ici
va rester au moins deux semaines
[Musique]
direction la belgique où les autorités
gouvernementales ont annoncé
l'interdiction à bruxelles d'un convoi
paneuropéen pour la liberté
selon des informations relayées sur les
réseaux sociaux le convoi attendu le 14
février prochain rassemblerait des
milliers de véhicules en provenance de
plusieurs capitales européennes le
mouvement de contestation pourrait
également s'étendre outre atlantique la
maison blanche dit en effet avoir été
avertie d'une convergence de camions à
washington au début du mois prochain